these protesters want global attention
their target on Sunday the United States
to China's leaders this will fuel their
suspicions that foreign powers are
behind the three and a half months of
unrest in Hong Kong the protesters
message is for the US Congress and the
act they want passed that would lead to
closer scrutiny of human rights in Hong
Kong and US sanctions against Hong
Kong's leaders he wants the u.s.
Congress to pass the Hong Kong human
rights and democracy as soon as possible
this bill be so important for us because
it can selectively punish those
officials who trample on our freedom
riot police blocked the road in front of
the consulate and were braced for
trouble as in previous demonstrations
these marchers represented a broad
cross-section of Hong Kong society on
Tuesday Hong Kong will be under the
international spotlight once more when
the United Nations Human Rights Council
meets in Geneva with China's
representative expected to defend the
Hong Kong police is handling of the
current turmoil Sunday's protest comes
five days after the chief executive
Carrie Lam announced she would
officially withdraw the controversial
extradition bill that set off the unrest
there was further trouble on Sunday
night when police and protesters clashed
in a main subway station parts of which
were vandalized Adrian Brown al Jazeera
Hong Kong